今日は外したそうです俺の最近を聞いてくれ
とりあえずね10月から学校が始まったんですよ大学生ですで普通にまあ日中は最近
ずっと学校に行ってて夕方家に帰ってきてすぐ動画ってっセグ
研修して出すみたいな最近はねそういう生活を送っているわけなんですよ
で何趣味で遊戯王カードをしててよね
階下に音こそニジェールスペースとかカードショップに行って夜によくこうデールを
繰り広げているんですよ
簡単にはこれは今3日な次元をね広域してるわけなんだよ各校の自分と中チューブの
自分とジュリストの自分は別にねなんか嫌じゃないんですね動画もねもちろん楽しいの
ぶっちゃけ動画がね一番なんだ結局はなそうなっちゃうんだよな
動画激励
一番なんだけどよいいよも辞めれないんだよねかつ当院ルウエストとして世界中で売り
する鳥がしたい負けたくないんで8耐んではプリキュアってサーブの普通の子の学校の
女子正答として生きるプリキュア後アクトを倒すっていうこの2つの世界を行き来して
てプリキュアあるねえ
2つの次元を1中だけでさああんな日で大変なんだよ二つの授業
をいっきしてるだけであんな待遇俺3次元だから願っコード youtube の言う
ように世界俺はねこうさあ3つの世界を行き来してんだよヤバイよハイパー
ハイパーハート9理由はだからね
って言えねっ
ちょっとね動画とるといけないはちょっとのんびりしたい訳ヨハながらジュルーピーク
は今日はこちらで
栗ピックサンド尻ティック山道ですよ
いいでしょうこれ室内用お砂遊びてことには今までに経験したことがないふすぎな済む
の
なんか感触に癒されます滝さん
ございません作る楽しみにはあ
ずっというわけでこれちょっといただきままたんですよ本当にありがとうございます
大砂だー2元祖リー
ラッシュマネーしたね昔はもう俺自体が砂みたいな感じだったらねグラウンドサス
なくっている後輩がいてさー
そのまま空ケースで運ばれチョップした別に俺は常食えていってなったっては後輩勝手
に繰り出してさ
俺はそれ見てたからさあ何か俺が悪いみたいになっちゃってさ
砂はあんまり食わない方がいいよこんな感じです
俺砂ここで開けていいのかなぁ
いいでしょ
えなんかこれ部屋がヤバイことにならないよん
[音楽]
うん
なんかヴィレッジヴァンガードの匂いがするちょっと今のところまだ判断ができない
でもなんかに感触はすごいね
は軽くの関税すげーわかるか何カッ
うわーってなってるのわかります
なんかボツボツしてるね普通の差なんじゃないっぽい感触金もすごい
本ゆんこグランデできそうなんか何かで来そうなんだよねーおじさんが手に持ってたら
すごい
めっちゃポロポロ落ちるんだよ
そりゃそうだわかるこの届ける間水
これねまし思ったこれ顔ね彼は見る録るの顔が多分
形状記憶されて俺の顔になるんだよ
[音楽]
なんか嫌だなこういうのはぜひねみんなを切りティックサンドリラックスしたい時は
やってみましょう see you next じゃあな
[音楽]
me